well joining me now to reveal some
reality shows secrets that can wait for
this are a few of my favorite
bachelorettes Ali Fedotowsky Desiree
Siegfried and from New York Andi Dorfman
welcome ladies okay here's what I want
to know are there any times where you do
a makeout scene and they go oh wait we
missed that close-up shot can you do
that kiss again
that never happened that never happened
no thanks they just make sure they get
it
okay so no makeout redos but another
maxim rent rumor we heard that there's
someone called a tear Wrangler rumor is
there is a producer paid to get the
girls to cry reduces you trust them so
much you're encouraged to open up to
them and you totally do and you try to
have in you so I could understand what
people would call that the tear range
but it's not like their sole job maybe
it is their sole job but we just don't
know I there's so many tears on the show
but it's happens any what happens yes
and you know all those limo exits guy in
a cupcake guy in a Santa suit guy on
unicorn hot shirtless guy with tats
yep producers helped come up with those
to how much of it is the producers idea
the producers not forcing you to get the
unicorn but I'm pretty sure that the guy
did not show up to LA with the unicorn
but so I mean I'm there's a little bit
of both for sure you could mention the
dumbest idea possible they like hats at
that radius yeah and how about all that
drinking what is the earliest time to
drink starts kind of start at the ATM Oh
any time
oh really I mean yeah friends if you've
always wonder like why do people get so
drunk like it's the first night not
everyone realizes that that person I
goes from about 8:00 p.m. till 8:00 a.m.
yeah so there's a good 12 hours of
drinking and just but really downtime
because a lot of times you're just
sitting around being bored you start
drinking you don't even realize so when
you see people passed out there not
necessarily drunk there's a potty hired
auditioning for the Bachelorette is
intense there's a psych evaluation and
contestants are asked are you on birth
control and do you have a sex tape I
think they asked if there were like nude
photos online of me and I'm like oh yes
seriously it's like a hundred I need a
305 and it's a huge packet like a psych
test that you guys have it's funny
people always say to me they're like oh
is it so they make sure you're not
crazy I was like or making what are
crazy of course being the Bachelorette
has perks there is Fame and he has a new
book it's not okay which is out now
Desiree wrote my fairy tale wedding Ali
has a blog and OH both Ali and Desiree
are expecting I'm 33 weeks so I'm doing
seven weeks here this Christmas baby
Chris is back on The Bachelorette
yes I'm doing October settle the rumors
now you know there are rumors that
you're dating Chris Harrison oh I like
how you start with pregnancy and I go to
conspiracy talk about that Angela no
definitely not dating Chris Harrison he
is my dear friend I think Chris will
ever date somebody within the bachelor
family I like your she'll tree doesn't
cross that line think how funny guys
thank ya inside scoop after we have
these babies give us some drinks and
we'll tell you oh yeah
Whitley